Is this introduction weird?
Yes, it's.
If "it's" is just a contraction
of "it" and "is",
then why doesn't that work?
In fact, why didn't English
just do a find-and-replace
on all the contractions?
I'm sure there'dn't've been
any problems with that.
Ah. Well, how do we understand
where the problem's with this?
I was supposed to've'd a
brilliant idea here,
but it appears...
it'sn't.
Okay, let's expand those back out.
That took me about
seventeen takes to get right.
Why don't those
contractions work?
Let's talk about "it's" in that
introductory line.
"It" is just a pronoun,
doing its job,
referring to something that's
established earlier
or obvious from context.
But what's the "'s"?
You can't even really
say it on its own.
It's just kind-of leaning on
the "it" for substance.
Which is why the technical term
for it is "clitic",
from the Ancient Greek "enklitikos",
meaning "to lean on".
A clitic is a part of speech that
can't exist just on its own.
Now, we've talked about things
like this before:
prefixes, suffixes and
other affixes,
things that attach to words
like ‘-able' or ‘un-'.
But a clitic isn't one of those.
And we know that because it doesn
t attach to individual words:
it attaches to a phrase,
a bigger part of speech.
So using a prefix or affix,
you can go from a dog to a
proto-dog or an anti-dog
or an astro-dog.
Or you can say that something
is "dog-ish".
Those all attach to the word "dog".
If you add some detail, you say
"my beautiful, green, astro-dog",
not "my astro-beautiful, green, dog".
That doesn't work.
For a clitic, it's different.
"My astro-dog's been learning tricks."
There's the clitic, just after "dog".
Let's add some more detail.
"My astro-dog from Jupiter's
been learning tricks."
That movement of 's,
within the sentence,
means it can't be an affix;
the ‘s behaves like it's the whole word,
like it's "has".
Not "is"… "has".
All that means that ‘s has to be
in its own category, it's a clitic.
But that doesn't explain why
it doesn't work sometimes.
If it was always possible to contract
‘is' and ‘has' down like that,
there might be an argument that
it's just a pronunciation thing?
There has to be some additional reason
that means "it'sn't" and "yes, it's"
are ungrammatical.
Now, if you want the full answer
to that, you can read
Anderson's "Aspects of the
Theory of Clitics",
but a quick warning, it is 287 pages long
not including the references and indices.
So to summarize as best as I can
for English: there are two reasons.
The first is what's called a Syntactic Gap
which means the presence
of the clitic
strongly implies that another
word should follow.
I think Anderson's best example is:
"Who do you think you're?"
...who do you think you're what?
Meeting? Talking to?
It feels like there
should be another word
in that syntactic gap,
the clitic is "stranded"
at the end.
And flipping that around,
if you say
"Who do you think
you are meeting?",
the sentence feels…
not ungrammatical,
but maybe a little
awkward and robotic.
And very much tied to that
is the second reason:
stress patterns.
Part of the reason these forms
can be reduced so much
is because they're generally
unstressed, or weak.
They're pronounced quieter
and less distinctly.
You cannot stress a clitic, and
it sounds weird when you try.
So let's try!
If a child's parent is pestering them
because they haven't cleaned up,
the kid can reply
"i AM going to do it",
that's called ‘rejoiner emphasis',
but they can't say
"iMMM going to do it". Doesn't work.
So if the verb would contextually
be in its weak form, unstressed,
and it also starts with
/w/, /h/, or a vowel,
it can get even more reduced
to this clitic form.
So, we get "we'll," "they've,"
"you'd," I'm," and so on.
Repeat enough times,
they become grammaticalized,
and they start to get
written like that as well.
In theory, something like
"there'd'n't've'" could work.
After all, "shouldn't've" is grammatical
in spoken English, as in
"I shouldn't've done that."
Actually, in my dialect,
if I'm talking quickly,
I pronounce that as either /ʃədənə/
or even just /ʃədn/.
Like, "/ʃədn/ done that".
Languages change and evolve over time,
words become clitics,
can stay that way for a while
and then eventually they may
start to sound ungrammatical
to future generations.
After all,
we used to say "'tis" not "it's",
so who knows:
in a century or two,
maybe "there'd'n't've"
will be perfectly
unremarkable English.
If you want more detail about this,
there's a whole episode
on my co-author Gretchen McCulloch's
podcast "Lingthusiasm",
the link is on screen
or in the description.